You know why babies look so young?
They don’t smoke!
Also they’re babies!
Ok Jules wrote this joke didn't he?
Hey puffy people, Julian here for Dnews!
We all know smoking can dramatically shorten
your lifespan and give you a whole host of
terrible diseases.
But did you know it can also make you look
like you chose poorly when trying to figure
out which cup is the Holy Grail?
For non-fans of Indiana Jones, in which case…
why?, what I’m trying to say is that smoking
can make you look older than you are, and
not in a good way, like a beard might.
And that’s not just anecdotal.
In November 2013, a study in the Journal of
the American Society of Plastic Surgeons compared
79 pairs of twins at a Twins Day Festival
in Twinsburg, Ohio.
That’s a lot of twins.
Anyway, they only chose pairs where one was
a smoker and the other a non-smoker, or, if
they were both smokers, that one had smoked
for five years longer than the other.
The researchers took photographs of the twins
to plastic surgeons, and asked them to point
out “specific components of facial aging”
related to smoking, and to figure out which
of the two was the smoker.
57 percent of the time, the surgeons got it
right and pointed out parts of the face which
reflected smoke-related aging the most.
Specifically, smokers were more likely to
have redundant or saggy eyelid skin, bags
under the eyes, baggy skin on the cheekbones
(also called malar bags or festoons), nasolabial
folds (or laugh lines), upper and lower lip
wrinkles, and jowls.
But, why?
Why does smoking make you look like Rip Van
Winkle?
Well, part of it has to do with nicotine’s
effect as a vasoconstrictor, meaning, it narrows
your blood vessels, allowing less blood through.
Since oxygen is carried through the body by
blood, your skin receives less oxygen.
Skin cells need oxygen to rebuild themselves,
and when it is restricted, they do a worse
job, causing noticeable changes in the condition
of your skin.
In addition, smoking lowers the number of
red blood cells in your body.
Too few red blood cells, a condition called
anemia, can cause a loss of color in the skin,
making it appear grayer or lighter, also called
pallor.
While smokers might not always be clinically
anemic, they do see similar effects.
Additionally, smokers tend to have saggier
skin overall, but especially in the face.
This is because skin firmness and suppleness
is dictated by how much collagen is produced
by the body.
Collagen is a type of structural protein in
tissue, and a study from 2002 found that certain
types were synthesized about 20% less in smokers,
leading to premature facial wrinkling and
poor wound healing.
And don’t forget, poor wound healing also
means more scarring.
With saggy, scarred, pale skin, it’s no
wonder smoking makes you look older.
So, don’t start smoking kids.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
If you listen to music and podcasts and are
looking for a new Bluetooth speaker, check
out Monster’s reimagined boombox, the Monster
Blaster.
It’s available for monthly payments starting
at $25.
The Monster Blaster has the power to bring
music to life indoors and out.
Check it out at themonsterblaster.com/dnews.
So what if you want to quit smoking.
Well, we have a video about the best ways
to do that, here.
Did you ever smoke and noticed, you know,
things weren't so great up here?
Let us know about it in the comments, subscribe
for more and I'll see you next time on DNews.